après les états unis on reparle du
mariage homosexuel en france il y a le
débat de principe il a souvent été
évoquée mais c'est le débat juridique
qui est maintenant ouvert un groupe de
juristes a créé en effet un collectif
il estime qu'aucun élément du code civil
ne s'oppose à ces mariages et plusieurs
élus à paris notamment se disent prêts à
célébrer de telles unions dossier signé
gaël chauvin lors on dit un regard
tendre c'est tout ce que se permet
gérone quand il est en public avec
sylvain le couple vit ensemble depuis
plus d'un an
et s'il rêve aujourd'hui de mariage
c'est que le pacs seule reconnaissance
officielle possible de leur union n'est
pas une solution satisfaisante
si nous sommes taxés en cas de décès
sylvain peut très bien se retrouver à la
porte du jour au lendemain de ma famille
décide de leur expulsion ça s'est déjà
vu notamment dans les années les plus
noires
vous allez plus loin du célèbre s'agisse
encore et le pacs n'a pas permis de
répondre à cette question alors que le
mariage pourrait autre limite le pacs
n'est pas reconnue en dehors de
l'hexagone
il ne permet pas non plus l'adoption des
droits qu'apporterait le mariage s'il
était les gars c'est justement le cheval
de bataille de ce juriste pour lui le
mariage homosexuel n'est interdit par
aucune loi à l'époque de napoléon
c'était tellement évident que les
compléter hétérosexuels qui n'ont même
pas pensé à introduire la définition du
mariage qu'on est en l'union d'un homme
et d'une femme
eh bien nous allons jouer justement là
des dents nous allons essayer de faire
interpréter l'absence de définition du
mariage comme étant donc la porte
ouverte au mariage homosexuel
voici le c'est l'article qui restreint
le mariage l'homme avant 18 ans révolus
la femme avant 15 ans révolus ne peuvent
contracter mariage
seul l'âge est imposé l'hétérosexualité
du couple est seulement implicite
alors dans ce vide juridique s'engouffre
certains mais jacques boutault par
exemple se dit prêt à marier des couples
du même sexe dans la mairie du 2e
arrondissement parisien
lorsqu on se marie on promet fidélité
secours et assistance à l'autre personne
du couple je crois qu'ils les
discriminant d'interdire cette
possibilité à deux personnes qui
souhaitent le faire au prétexte qu'elle
serait du même sexe
mais qu'elle soit de droite ou de gauche
peu de maires acceptent l'idée de
célébrer ce genre d'union ses
détracteurs mettent en avant la vocation
première du mariage est fait pour les
gens de sexe opposé et dayraut sexuelle
qui veulent vivre ensemble ont créé
stade où nous sommes je considère que
c'est au législateur de se prononcer aux
etats unis le maire de san francisco
avait exploité le même type de faille
juridique puisque à ce que la cour
suprême suspendent les mariages
homosexuels